when we think of the largest retailers
in the world the first companies that
come to mind are walmart and amazon if
you thought a bit harder you'd probably
name target costco sam's club and the
home depot but what about ikea we all
know about ikea and have probably
shopped there in the past but for most
people ikea is not the first retailer
that comes to mind and this isn't a
coincidence either for how large ikea is
they keep an extremely low profile you
don't see many articles talking about
how ikea is a monopoly or that its
founder is actually lex luthor we also
don't see analysts giving outlooks for
ikea's revenue or putting out price
predictions for ikea stock because the
company is private ikea is one of those
things that we all know about but we
never talk about and that's a shame
given how impressive and substantial
their business is
so here's the story of ingbar comprod
and how he became the 58.7 billion
dollar shadow retailer
taking a look back ingvar was born quite
a while ago on march 30th 1926 in pyotr
red sweden he grew up on a small farm
called elm turret located in the village
of agunard ingvar was born right before
the great depression and his parents
weren't particularly wealthy so the
depression was a pretty rough experience
for the family everyone in the little
village was just trying to survive on a
day-to-day basis by saving every penny
and wasting nothing most kids were
expected to work on the farm during the
day and help out with house chores in
the evening but despite the comrade
family's desperate state they never
forced ingvar to help it seems that
though they couldn't give ingvar
financial freedom they wanted him to
have the freedom of spending his time
how he wanted inkbar was never too
interested in working on the farm or
doing house chores but from a very early
age he wanted to help the family
financially so at 5 ingvar decided to
start selling matches to his neighbors
for pennies ingvar barely made any money
from this endeavor given the cheap
nature of matches but it's crazy to
think that ingvar levitated towards
business at age five fortunately as
ingvar grew older he delved into some
more profitable ventures ingvar sold
pens pencils christmas tree decorations
and most importantly fish selling fish
was the first time that inkvar addressed
a gap in the market you see many farmers
in this village didn't have fishing
licenses but ingvar's father did so
catching fish and selling it to these
farmers was a rather profitable idea
ingbar even got his father to become an
investor in the business and buy him
larger nets which substantially
increased his yield despite his side
hustle going decently well ingvar's
parents wanted him to complete basic
education so they sent ingvar to a
nearby boarding school at age 14. school
was quite hard for inkwar though because
he was dyslexic however a promise from
his father motivated ingvar to work
super hard at school ingvar's father
promised that if ingvar got good grades
in school and graduated he would pay the
registration fees for setting up
ingvar's first business ingvar put his
head down and worked his way through
school by age 17 and as promised his
father paid for invoice business
registration fees and ingvar had the
freedom to choose the name ingvar chose
to keep it simple and personal he based
the first two letters of the name on his
initials ik and he based the third and
fourth letter on the village and form he
was born on e for um turret and a for a
gunnerad and with that inkfor launched
ikea at age 17 in 1943. ingvar had saved
up a decent amount of money throughout
his childhood but his savings were
nothing in comparison to established
retailers in the area so ingvar focused
on starting a business that had super
low costs his first idea was to create a
mail-order business that sold wallets
photo frames pins and other small items
this business model allowed ingvar to
completely eliminate storage costs but
similar to his match business ingvar
barely made any money due to the cheap
nature of the items he was selling so in
1948 ingvar decided to expand to
furniture even with furniture ingvar
stocked to the mail-order business model
to keep costs low he delivered the
furniture using trucks and trains and
his business started to grow quite
rapidly but his personal life was a lot
more questionable around this time invar
joined a group called the new sweden
movement led by a man named per engdahl
per engdahl was a fascist and this was
during the height of world war ii so
ingbar had basically joined a youth
fascist group he later explained that
this decision was largely influenced by
his father and grandmother given that he
joined the group at age 16. ingwar's
primary role within the organization was
to raise funds and recruit new members
for the group inkfor's involvement
didn't become public till 50 years later
though in 1994 when pearl engdahl's
personal letters were made public we
don't know when ingvar left the
organization but there's evidence
suggesting that ingvar remained friends
with engdahl up until the early 1950s
ingvar did publicly apologize for his
involvement and acknowledged that it was
a massive mistake but this is
nonetheless a dark spot in his life
anyway going back to ikea it didn't take
long for inkvar to double down on the
furniture business given the much larger
profit per unit by the early 1950s
ingwar removed everything else from
ikea's catalog and ikea officially
became a furniture company about a
decade after starting the business invar
opened up ikea's very first showroom in
1953. the showroom was especially
effective at converting shoppers into
paying customers given that they could
actually see the furniture but as ikea
grew established furniture players
weren't exactly pleased to see another
competitor entering the scene
so they banded together and tried to
take down ikea they called up ikea's
suppliers and told them that they would
stop buying furniture from them if they
continued to supply ikea
in fear of preserving their own
businesses the suppliers bent to this
request and stopped supplying ikea i'm
sure this was an extremely stressful
time for ingvar but some of the best
ideas emerged under the most stressful
circumstances and this couldn't be truer
for ingor since he couldn't buy
furniture from the popular suppliers
ingpar decided to design his own
furniture that was simple and cheap
inkbar made a couple of deals with
foreign suppliers for the materials and
with that ingbar was back in business
ironically this experience allowed
ingvar to cut out the middleman's
suppliers which only further reduced the
price of his furniture making ikea even
more popular now that ikea was making
their own furniture ink for had more
freedom when it came to how the
furniture was packaged and that brings
us to ikea's breakthrough renovation
which is of course their flat box diy
furniture by shifting the assembly
process to the consumer ingvar was able
to drastically reduce shipping and labor
costs now of course this completely cut
out the premium furniture buying market
premium furniture buyers weren't
particularly impressed with ikea's
choice of materials or their
build-it-yourself model however for the
vast majority of us peasants acceptable
quality furniture for super low prices
is more than enough this new flat box
design also meant that ikea didn't need
to store their furniture at warehouses
and ship it to customers they could just
store it in the showrooms and have
customers take it home with them which
reduce costs even further in 1965 ingbar
opened ikea's first retail outlet in
stockholm sweden ikea had already
expanded internationally a few years
before this in 1963 with the opening of
a showroom in norway but the modern ikea
didn't make its debut until 1965. around
the same time inkbar also opened the
first ikea restaurant in 1960. ingvar
noticed that customers generally left
the store during lunch time to eat at
one of the restaurants across the street
so in an effort to plead fewer customers
during lunch time ingvar opened a
kitchen which turned out to be a massive
success
just as everything was progressing
forward though ingvar would be hit with
some bad luck in 1970 an electrical
problem would start a fire at the
stockholm ikea the fire caused a lot of
damage and was quite expensive to repair
but somehow even this turned into a good
thing given that a large portion of the
store had to be shut down while it was
being repaired inkbar introduced a
self-service area that he hoped would
reduce congestion and give customers
more freedom
and as we now know it this became a
permanent change that also reduced costs
throughout the rest of the decade ikea
focused on opening retail outlets
outside of scandinavia including
switzerland and germany ikea opened
their first u.s store in 1985 and
they've exploded internationally ever
since
by the end of the century ikea had grown
to 114 outlets spread across 25
countries and that brings us to their
last major avenue of growth which was
the internet in 2000 ikea began selling
their furniture over the internet and
this quickly cemented them as the
world's largest furniture retailer given
how enormous ikea is today i don't think
you'd be surprised to hear that ingvar
was worth 23 billion dollars by march of
2010 or that it both grew to a peak of
58.7 billion dollars in june of 2015
making him the eighth richest person in
the world but ingvar hated the publicity
he got for his wealth and he actively
tried to avoid it ingvar set up a super
convoluted set of holding companies and
foundations that were all independent of
each other being far spread as well to
cross these holding companies and made
it so that no major decision could be
made without approval from all of them
ingvar felt that this was the best way
to ensure that one of his children or a
future leader of ikea didn't screw up
the business by making some sort of rash
decision he also made it so that neither
he nor his children could withdraw money
from these holding companies so on paper
ingvar no longer had access to this
money and his net worth was slashed to a
little over three billion dollars
this didn't really matter much to him
though given that he never lived like a
billionaire in the first place in fact
not only did he live a modest life but
he was actually insanely frugal on the
surface he lived in a modest house and
only flew economy and stayed at budget
hotels but his frugal habits stretched
much further than just that anger hated
paying for haircuts in the netherlands
because they often cost him up to 27
dollars
so whenever ingvar visited an ikea store
in a third world country he would just
get a haircut there he also purchased a
lot of clothes at nearby flea markets i
think we can all agree that he is really
quite a character unfortunately though
ingvar passed away a few years ago on
january 27 2018
but he was 91 years old at the time and
there's no doubt that he lived an
extremely productive and accomplished
life do you guys like ikea's furniture
comment that down below
also drop a like if you love ikea's
prices
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hurry and i'll see
you guys on the next one